Lisbakken:
All right. Hello, everyone.
My name's Ben Lisbakken,
and I'm an engineer
at Google.
And it looks like you guys
have all made it to my session
on "Fun Hacks
and Cool JavaScript."
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to talk about
my process in creating
the Google AJAX API Playground.
What I really wanted to do
is just talk about
some of the techniques
that I used to create it
and some of the things that
I've learned along the way
that I thought were, you know,
really important things
that I learned
that I'd like to share.
So let's jump
right into the outline.
First I'll show you guys
what the AJAX API Playground is,
since I'm sure all of you
don't know exactly what it is.
Then I'll go into
some JavaScript,
so I'll show some intermediate
and advanced techniques
that you can use
in JavaScript.
After that, I'll talk about some
of the cool hacks that I did
in the Playground--
some stuff that I really
had a lot of fun doing.
Then I'll go into XSRF,
which is a security
vulnerability--
vulnerability,
excuse me.
And after that
I'll talk about
front-end web performance.
So let's take a look at
the AJAX API Playground.
What is it?
It's an interactive
JavaScript code editor
that allows you to edit code
and then run it
on the exact same page.
Its primary use right now
is for showing
Google AJAX API examples.
However, it's an open source
framework that I created,
so you can really use it
for any JavaScript code
that you want to show.
You can also edit HTML and CSS
in addition to JavaScript.
That's a recent feature
that I added.
And why did I make it?
I made it because
when I'm learning APIs,
it's really difficult to go
through the documentation
and figure out exactly
what's going on.
It's also really hard to find
what you can do with an API
just by looking
at the documentation.
So samples are really king,
for me.
I believe that if you
look through ten samples
then you'll have a better idea
of what you want to do.
And, in addition,
by looking through
the actual code,
you'll have a better idea
of how to accomplish it.
So let's go ahead and
take a look at the Playground.
That is huge.
Let's see.
Can you guys all--can you guys
see that pretty well?
In the back?
Can you guys see the code?
Anyone back there?
Looks good?
Okay, so here's
the Playground.
On the left hand side
is the pick div.
And this allows you to select
from various JavaScript APIs
that Google offers,
and see some samples
on them.
So right here I am going
to list some blogs.
You'll see the codes over here
on the right-hand side.
It's a little bit squished
because it wasn't meant
for a projector.
But down here
is the output div,
and it shows the output
of the sample.
Let's take a look
at another sample--
a calendar sample.
So this is just
a simple sample
for showing the events
from a calendar.
And in this case,
we're looking at
the Google Developer calendar,
so you can see that one of
the events is this conference.
Let's go back up
to a Translate example.
Up here you'll see
it's just really simple.
Take some text,
it's in Spanish,
and it turns it to English.
So let's look at the code.
You'll see here we've got
the original text,
the Spanish,
and then down here
is this block of code
for translating it.
So what if I wanted
to edit this example?
I could go ahead and throw
an alert in here.
I'm just going to alert
the number 1.
And come down
and click "Run".
And there you see
it prints out "1"
just like i wanted it to.
So the reason why I created
the Playground like this
is because when you're looking
through sample code,
it's really hard to go
from seeing the sample code
to getting to the point where
you're actually going to be
editing it and doing
what you want to do with it.
So the way this format works,
it makes it a lot easier
than seeing a sample,
copying the code
to a new document,
putting it on your server,
and then actually being able
to play around with edit it--
with editing it.
Instead, with the Playground,
you just jump right in,
see a sample that you like,
maybe you want to tweak it,
see if it can possibly do
what you're trying to do,
and then run with that.
So what happens
if you want to debug?
Well, I added some features
in there for debugging.
So right here,
I just added a breakpoint
on line 11.
I'm going to go ahead
and click "Debug Code"
and it's now going
to pause it on line 11.
And this right here
is my continue button.
I can continue through
executing the code,
or if I want, I can open up
Firebug Lite in the bottom,
and I can actually
log one of my variables.
So I think, up here,
if you look,
I have a variable in this
function called "content".
So...come back down here
and see
what "content" is equal to.
And sure enough,
we get a div.
If you go look at the top,
"content" is equal to a div
that we have grabbed.
So that's how you debug.
Well, let me show you
the quick--
finishing through
the breakpoint.
It, sure enough,
goes through,
calls the alert, and then
it will finish the translation.
So that's how you edit code
and debug it.
What if you edit
some code substantially
and you want
to hold onto it for later?
There's a save feature.
So you can go through
and you can--"My IO SAMPLE".
Big caps 'cause
it's a cool sample.
Not really.
And so now you have
a new div
when you go into the Playground
called "Saved Code".
And...it's now got my sample
that I've just saved.
You can also go
and share code with friends.
So if you want to break out
of the box of the Playground
and actually, you know, show
someone else what you've done,
you can click "Export".
We'll now export the code
to a standalone URL.
So you can use
this sticky URL
to show to your friends,
and it'll exist forever.
And go in and see and this is
all of the sample code
for that exact sample that
I was just taking a look at.
So there's about 188 samples
in the AJAX API Playground.
So I really suggest
going through
and taking a look at them.
I mean, a lot of people
are interested in Maps.
So there's just a ton
of different Maps samples
for everything
you'd want to do.
Search as well--
putting Search in your site,
it's really easy,
and there's samples
for absolutely every different
API call that we have.
So if you're interested
in JavaScript APIs from Google,
definitely take a look
at the Playground.
So let's go ahead and
get into some Meteor code.
I want to talk
about JavaScript,
and the reason why
is because
lots of web apps use--
well, almost all web apps
use JavaScript.
And JavaScript's
really easy to use
and it's really easy
to cut and paste.
However, generally,
people don't know
JavaScript really well.
So I wanted to take some time
to talk about the coolness
of JavaScript--
some of the intermediate
and advanced stuff
that you can do
in JavaScript.
And I've always wanted
to go to a session
when I was learning JavaScript
that would talk about,
you know,
some of these cool functions,
some of the cool things
that you can do.
So a quick warning:
if any of you are experts
in JavaScript out there,
you'll probably be bored
for the next 15 minutes
'cause I'm going
to go through
some intermediate
JavaScript stuff.
If you're a beginner,
then you might get
a little bit lost,
especially if
I'm talking too fast.
I'm going to go through
a couple, like,
really important concepts
to learn in JavaScript,
and generally you can't
learn them in 15 minutes.
So feel free to ask questions
as I go through them,
but also,
you can follow along with me
on your computers,
and you can check out
the URL after
to look at the stuff.
And I highly suggest looking up
additional information.
Also, the code
that I'm showing for you--
I just wrote it up, you know,
really quickly
for this presentation,
so it's not battle-tested.
It's not meant to be
copy and pasted.
It's just, you know,
for education.
So let's jump right in.
I decided to add
JavaScript samples
for my presentation
into the actual Playground.
Go ahead and delete that.
And here they are.
So let's start out in JavaScript
with defining objects
and creating prototypes.
The first step is
creating an Object Literal.
So what's an Object Literal?
It's just a format for
defining objects in JavaScript,
and it's
a comma separated list
of properties and methods
for an object.
And it's a dynamic way
to create an object,
and it's used for creating
a Singleton--
so just one instance
of this object
that you're going to use
over and over again.
So take a look down here.
I'm creating a variable, "A".
And I'm setting it equal
to these brackets here.
That means that I'm setting it
equal to an object.
And here you'll see
the contents of this object.
I basically have
key value pairs,
and the key value pairs
are the--
property one is equal
to the number 1,
then I have arr
which is equal to an array,
then I have doThis
which is equal to a function,
and two which is, again,
equal to an integer.
So right off the bat
you can see that
JavaScript's a really
dynamic language.
I've made an object that has
very different properties in it.
So if you take a look
down here in the output,
I'm just going to show
how you use it.
So a.doThis
is recalling that function.
And it is outputting 20,
as you can see up here.
And same with the array--
we're going to a.arr
and--and you see,
0 is in fact equal to 1,
which you'll see up here.
On to adding properties
to an object.
So it's easily--
it's easy to dynamically add
properties to an object
because objects
kind of just behave
like hash tables,
key value pairs.
And I'm going to show you
how to do that right here.
I'm going to create
a variable "A"
and it's equal
to a blank object,
an object
with nothing in it.
Down here I'm going
to give "A" two properties:
property1
and property2.
And they're both going
to be equal to integers.
Now, you'll notice that
the syntax is a little different
for both of these.
One of these is
a.property1
and the other one
is using "A"
as if it were an array.
This is, effectually,
going to assign the properties
to "A" the exact same way.
So another example
of how JavaScript's,
you know,
kind of dynamic.
There's a lot of different
ways to do things in JavaScript.
So it gives you
a lot of flexibility.
And then, down here,
I'm going to show
how to dynamically
add a new function too.
So I'm going to create
function3
and set it
equal to a function
which uses--which is just
going to take property1
and property2
and add them together
and return the output.
Notice that I'm using
the "this" keyword.
In JavaScript,
"this" just refers
to the object that we're in.
So right now we're in "A"
so we're referring
to "A" property1
and "A" property2.
So now let's go on
to inheritance.
In JavaScript,
to do inheritance,
you use prototypes.
And so what you use
prototypes for
is to add properties
or methods
to all instances
of an object.
So I'm going to create
a Dog down here.
And when you visit the
constructor function for a Dog,
and when you create a Dog you're
gonna pass in a barkNoise.
In the constructor
I'm going to set this instances
of the barkNoise
to be equal
to whatever's passed in.
So when you pass in
the barkNoise,
that instance of a Dog
is now going to always have
a barkNoise.
Down here I'm going to use
the prototype keyword.
And the prototype keyword
is the magic that makes
inheritance possible.
So I'm saying each Dog is
going to have a bark function.
And I'm doing this
just by saying
Dog.prototype.bark
is equal to function.
So whenever
I create a new one,
it'll always have
a bark function.
Same with
the numLegs property.
I'm making it so
Dog.prototype is saying
that each Dog is going to have
the numLegs property.
Down here is how
I actually create the Dogs.
I say new Dog,
and I'm going to have
a tinyDog that yaps
a bigDog
which has a very deep,
burly woof.
And after that, I will
assign some properties
to these instances.
I'll give them
each a size,
just say it's--
tinyDog's tiny,
and the bigDog's big.
And this is just showing,
on the last example,
how you add properties
to an object.
Nothing too crazy
on the output.
I'm just, you know, showing
that this did in fact work.
The tinyDog is tiny,
it has 4 legs,
the bigDog is big,
and it has 4 legs,
and here are
their barkNoises--
yap yap and woof.
So you can override
prototypes too.
So if an object
already has a prototype
defined for it,
then you can override it.
You can rewrite it
to do what you want.
You can also create
new prototypes for that.
So you can do this on
native JavaScript types as well.
So you can do this
for strings
or integers or functions.
You could actually override
JavaScript's native behavior.
Now, this is very dangerous
to do that--
to override a native
JavaScripts type--
and so I'm saying
this is a bad example.
Please don't copy this one
because you could really screw
things up for other people.
And the reason why
is because
if you edit
a native JavaScript type,
and you include jQuery,
jQuery's going to be trying
to use a string function
just like it
would expect it to work.
But if you're changing
the native JavaScript type,
then when you include jQuery,
it's going to fail.
But why am I
showing you this?
The reason why
I'm showing you this
is because in some cases
you will want to override
prototypes that exist.
So, for instance, if I was
including jQuery on my site,
and I didn't like the way that
they did one of their functions
or if I wanted to have
each jQuery object
have a new property
or a new method
across every single one,
then I'd want to use
this stuff right here.
So here is a simple example
where I am changing
the concatenation function
for strings.
Normally
it just takes one string
and concatenates it
with another.
But in this example,
I'm actually going to take
one string,
put a delimeter,
and then add on
the other string.
So nothing crazy.
The syntax for this is
just like you would expect.
Just in the last example,
you've just
defined the prototype.
But since the concat
already exists,
we're overriding it.
Then down here I'm going to add
a new function onto string's.
I'm going to make it so that
you can call a string.reverse.
So you can reverse a string
in place.
And all that's going to do
is print it backwards.
Down here in the output,
you can see how it would work.
If "A" was equal
to abc,
and "B" was equal
to def,
if we called a concat,
like that,
then, of course,
we get that output
and a.reverse
will reverse the string "A".
Conditional Assignment--
this is a very simple example
to show.
The reason why
I wanted to show it
is because for those of you
that don't know it,
you'll see this a lot,
and I think it's elegant.
I really like it.
All you're doing here
is conditionally--
conditionally setting "B".
We're saying that
if "A" is equal to 1,
then set "B" to 2,
Otherwise, set it to 1.
So now on to JSONP.
JSONP is a little bit
of a hard concept to explain.
Basically,
it's a technique
for avoiding the browser's
cross-domain restriction.
So if you guys
aren't familiar with that,
that just means that
if you're on domain 1,
and you try and do
an AJAX request
to domain 2,
because of the browser's
security model,
you're not allowed
to do that.
But with JSONP
you can actually
get around that.
And so what's JSONP used for?
Well, Google uses it a lot
in our APIs.
We provide APIs
that allow you to request
data from us in JavaScript
and do it cross-domain.
So the basics of it
is that on the client side,
you create
a new script tag,
you give that script tag
a source,
give it a type,
and then you add it
to your page.
So what's going to happen
is whatever's--
as you guys know,
with a script tag,
whatever is returned by
the source that you're grabbing
is then going to be evaluated
by the JavaScript engine
and run.
Well, JSONP--
in JSONP,
the service is going to return
the data that you request--
requested in a format
that will be executed
by JavaScript.
So right here--
here's the--here's the source
that I am setting the scripts
to be equal to.
And it's really hard to read
but you might notice that it's--
it's an Object Literal.
I showed that. That was
the first sample that I showed.
So it's basically
a string of data
written as
a JavaScript object.
So if we look in here, what is
this service that I'm doing?
It's a web search,
a Google web search,
and I'm searching for dog--
I don't know if you guys--
yeah, you guys can see that.
So in these results
it will return me
the top queries for Dog.
The other thing to note is that
all of this JSON
is wrapped in a function call.
So what's going to happen
is when my page
evaluates this response,
it's immediately going
to execute this function
and pass in
this Object Literal,
and it's going
to be evaluated.
So I was calling myFunc.
As soon as this script
is added to the page,
it's going to call myFunc,
it's going to come in here,
and it's going
to log the response.
So let's take a look
at that response.
Go into Firebug,
check my log,
and sure enough,
this is the response.
And it's got a nice,
pretty format for us.
Go through and here are
my four results.
I have Wikipedia
and dog.com.
All right,
on to Anonymous Functions.
So an anonymous function
is just
a function
that's dynamically declared
that doesn't have a name.
So right here
is our anonymous function.
All we're doing is setting
the onload event
to be equal
to this anonymous function.
Nothing too interesting
there.
But this is why we would want
to use anonymous functions--
and the reason why
is because of the fact
that JavaScript
uses functional scope.
What that means is that
context--
scope in JavaScript
is defined by a function.
So if you define a variable
in an if statement
or a four-loop,
it doesn't matter.
All that matters is whether--
what function it's in.
So if you have a function and
you have stuff defined in it,
it won't be visible
outside of that function.
So that's--that's the
functional scope for JavaScript,
and the reason why
this is useful to know
is because a lot of times
in JavaScript--
well, in web pages
in general,
you always want to be including
other people's scripts.
Well, the problem with that
is that
all the names will collide.
If you guys
use the same names,
then you're going
to start having errors
because you guys will
override each other's data.
So knowing that JavaScript
operates like that--
where if you
have a function,
anything defined in it
won't be visible outside of it--
you can actually
hide all of your code.
You can hide it
so that your names
aren't affecting
the global scope.
And in JavaScript,
in the DOM,
the global scope
is the window object.
Just a little tidbit.
So down here I am going
to use this to my advantage
by creating
an anonymous function,
which spans down to here.
I'm going to wrap it
in parentheses
so that returns
the function.
And then right here
is the really important part,
where I'm going to automatically
call that function.
When that function
gets called,
it's going
to define everything
inside this function.
And everything
inside of this function
is now going to be
invisible outside.
So what I've done is
I've created a function
that has no name,
I've written all of my code--
let's say
my 2,000-line project--
I've written all my lines
within
this anonymous function,
and now, when someone
includes this on their page,
it won't pollute
any of the global namespace.
There won't be
a named function there.
Any of my variables
inside of the function--
none of them will exist
in the global scope.
So we'll have
no namespace collisions.
Excuse me.
Well, what if I wanted
to export something
from the inner function
to the outside?
Here's how you do it.
As I said,
the window object
is the global namespace,
so what I would do
is I'd attach a new variable
to the window object,
the global namespace,
and I'd set it
equal to a property
or a method
that I wanted to export.
So in this case, I'm exporting
visibleOutside function
to the global namespace.
And down here, I just did
a simple test to see.
What is the value
of these two functions
inside of
the anonymous function,
and what is
their value outside?
And you can see
that from the inside
we can see both of them.
They are both
of type function.
But from the outside
of the anonymous function,
you can't see
the invisible one
because we never exported it.
However, you can see
the visible one.
So for third party libraries,
they all are using
anonymous functions
to hide all of their
local variables.
And it's a good practice
to do it with your own code
because you never know
when someone's
going to reuse your code.
All right, on to
a really fun topic--Closure.
So closure is the source
of a lot of power in JavaScript.
And all it is
is it's when a function
is defined
within another function,
and that inner function
has access
to the outer function's
context and scope
even after that outer function's
already closed.
So right here--in fact,
in some of my examples
you've already seen--
the last example
had a closure in it.
I had an anonymous function
with code defined in it
with other functions.
And that was already
an example of closure.
But right here it's just
a very simple, obvious one.
I have an inner function
and I have an outer function.
And in the inner function,
I'm accessing
these two variables.
And these two variables
exist in the outer function.
So that's all
that closure is.
Here's how we'd--
how you'd use a closure.
One common way
is with setting events.
Basically when
an event handler is triggered,
if you're trying
to print out a value,
then whatever
you're trying to print out
is going to be the value
at trigger time.
But what if you wanted
to hard code
a value into that event
so that when
the event triggered
it printed out
whatever you wanted
when you had set the handler?
Well, you'd use
closure for this
because you can access
the outer function's variable
even after
the outer function is closed.
You'll understand more
in just a sec.
So this is the bad way to--
I'm going to create
five buttons.
five buttons the wrong way,
then I'm going to create them
the good way with closure.
So the bad way: here is
setting an onclick handler
the bad way.
I'm setting just--I'm just
making it equal to a function
that alerts a variable.
The problem with this
is that "I" is going to be--
when I click this button,
"I" is going to be equal
to whatever "I" is
at the time
that this is clicked.
So in this case, the four-loop's
going to go through.
It's going to iterate to 5.
And then when
you click the button,
"I" will be equal to 5.
And that'll happen for
every single one of the buttons.
But what I want
the behavior to be
is each button
that gets clicked
will output what number
button it is--
so, you know,
0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
So for that
I would use closure.
If you take a look
down here,
this is my good setters.
button.onclick is equal to
a function that I'm executing.
So I'm executing a function
which is then
going to return a function.
Up here is the function
that I'm executing.
I'm passing in "I".
So let's say the first--
let's go through
the first iteration.
In the first iteration,
we're going to call buttonClick.
It's going to pass in 0.
buttonNumber is going
to be equal to 0.
Within this context,
we're going to have
access to that variable.
And then we're going
to return a function.
This inner function,
because it's a closure,
has access to
the outer function's variables--
AKA buttonNumber.
So when you click this button
that uses closure,
it's going to alert
whatever value is snapshotted
inside of it
because of closure.
So that's a tough concept
to understand.
It definitely took me
a little while
to pick up on it.
So, you know, hopefully
I explained it decently.
At least you guys are aware
of more things
that exist in JavaScript--
more fun, cool tricks
that are
very heavily used.
So I hope that you guys
will go explore
more information on those.
Let's get into some
of the fun things that I did
in the Playground
to make it possible.
So there were three things
that I wanted to cover.
One is executing
arbitrary code safely.
The next is adding
the Debug Bar
and Firebug Lite
into the output.
And the last one
is adding breakpoints.
So executing arbitrary code...
I don't know if you guys
are familiar with eval,
but eval
lets you take a string--
so just a normal string--
and then JavaScript
will evaluate that string
as JavaScript.
So if you passed in the string
variable 1 is equal to 1
and you passed it into eval,
then you'd now have
this new variable
in your code.
Well, as you guys saw,
I allow you developers
to edit code
in the Playground.
And so that means
that I have to let you guys
be running
your own JavaScript,
whatever you guys
want to be running.
And it's bad to use eval
because it's going to be
happening on my domain.
So you developers
will be writing code--
JavaScript that gets run
on the google.com domain.
This is really bad
because
you guys could write code
that would steal cookies,
steal authenticated sessions,
and for obvious reasons,
that's really bad.
So I had to
come up with a solution
that would sandbox the code
that you guys were writing
so that you
couldn't do evil hacks.
So the solution is an iFrame,
and it's creating an iFrame
on another domain
that doesn't have access
to any of these cookies
or, you know, any private,
secure resources.
So when the user writes
code on the Playground
and then clicks "Run",
the Playground takes
that giant chunk of code
that they have,
it sends it to another server,
that server then stores it
in the database
and then it returns
a unique URL
to that code
that's over here.
The Playground
takes that URL
and it creates an iFrame
to that code.
So then the Playground's
got this iFrame
with the code running in it,
and it's a beautiful
little sandbox
because iFrames can't talk
to parent frames
if they're
in different domains.
So it completely
cuts off any vector of attack
in stealing cookies
or, you know,
any evil JavaScript stuff
bad developers
might try and do.
So let's talk about
adding the Debug Bar
and Firebug Lite
into the output.
This was
an interesting problem
because I wanted to add
my code and my interface
into code
that you guys are writing.
So I don't know
what you guys are writing
but I don't want
to conflict with it.
So what I did
was use some of the tricks
that I was showing
back when I was explaining
the JavaScript stuff.
I used an anonymous function
to hide all of my code.
You can see here
I have a variable: "anony",
that I'm setting equal
to this anonymous function
with all of my code that's
going to insert the Debug Bar
and insert Firebug Lite.
And so what that'll do
is when it--
the code gets sent over
to the--to the iFrame,
it will make it
so that my code
won't be in the namespace.
So if you guys are writing
a bunch of global variables
I won't conflict
with you.
Now there's
some interesting things
down here on the last line.
What I'm doing is I'm taking
this anonymous function--
which is, you know,
actually defined
in my Playground JavaScript--
and I'm using a fun little
method called "toString".
Now, you can imagine that you
would be able to call toString
on an integer
and turn it into a string,
but not too many people know
that you can take a function
and call toString on it.
The reason why this is nice
is 'cause
it's very convenient.
Since I'm taking code and
I have to turn it into a string
so that I can send it over
the wire to the other server,
I really don't want
to write my code in a string.
Like, I don't want
to put parentheses
or, excuse me, quotes
around all these lines
and have to write
new lines in there
because it's very ugly code.
So I did this:
I created an anonymous function,
I turned it
into a string,
I wrapped it in parentheses
and added
the autoexecute parentheses
so that once it ends up
on the other server
it'll be a string
and it'll be
an anonymous function
that autoexecutes itself.
So on to the real fun:
adding breakpoints.
You can add breakpoints
in JavaScript
via an extension.
So you guys are probably
all familiar with Firebug,
and Firebug has access
to the JavaScript engine.
So when they're
creating breakpoints,
they're actually
stopping and starting
the JavaScript engine again.
So they have direct access.
I didn't.
All I have access to
is JavaScript.
So I wrote breakpoints
for JavaScript
in JavaScript.
So it was
a fun little problem.
One of the interesting things
about it
was prever--
preserving execution context
so that once I went
into a breakpoint,
after I continued
out of it,
it would still contain
the correct context.
That way, any variables
that were being used
would still have access
to the local variables
that they should.
Another fun problem
was making sure that Firebug
still had access to print out
the local variables
while in a breakpoint.
So here's the before
and after code.
This--the before code
is the code that you,
a developer on the Playground,
might have written.
And the after code
is what I've done.
I've parsed your code
and added in some stuff
to make it possible
for a breakpoint to occur.
So on line 9 is where
we've inserted the breakpoint.
If you come down here
and look,
right after where you
inserted the breakpoint
I started inserting
my own code.
I call this function
setContinue,
and what that's going to do
is it's going to set
a global variable for me,
saying that yes,
we are, in fact,
at a breakpoint right now.
Then I've got
this big function here,
and you'll notice
that this is a closure.
I've got
this big function here
and it's going
to contain my logic
that allows me to loop back
over myself
until the user
has clicked "continue".
So I've got
this if statement:
"if window.doContinue".
So if the user
hasn't clicked "continue"
then call setTimeout
and recall myself
the closure function:
breakpointAtLine9.
Otherwise, if the user
has clicked "continue",
go ahead and execute
the rest of the code
that was supposed
to be executed--
so that's lines 10 and 11
up here.
So this is interesting--
I just wanted to point out
that variable "A"
equals text and alert "A"--
those are now possible
because it's a closure,
and so those
still have access
to this variable up here.
Now on to the Firebug problem.
Why was I still
able to print out
local variables
with Firebug?
Well, the problem is that when
you're in this setTimeout loop,
where it's looping
every 100 milliseconds
over my breakpoint function--
Firebug's over here.
When you try and log
with Firebug,
Firebug's not
in the same context.
It's got--it's in a completely
different context.
It can't see
these local variables.
And if--
some of you are familiar
with the apply
or call functions--
there's no way
to work those in
to force them to be
the correct function context.
So I had to get
a little bit of--
a little bit
more creative than that.
I basically made
this big hack
where I went
into Firebug's code,
their JavaScript code,
and I edited it so that
if Firebug is trying
to log something,
and it sees that
you're in a breakpoint,
then it's going to add
whatever you're trying to log
into a global queue.
In my breakpoint you see
this "if" statement right here.
It's going to check
that global queue,
and if there's stuff
in the global queue,
then it's going to log it.
The reason why this works
is because
when you log it in here,
it has the correct context.
So it was my little ninja way
of sneaking Firebug
into the correct context.
All right, so enough about
JavaScript's context
and--and all that stuff.
Let's get into security.
So XSRF is
a common security hole,
and it's
a very serious one too.
I definitely
didn't know about it
when I was creating
the Playground.
But after doing
a security review,
I certainly found out
about it.
What it is
is it's when evil.com
tries to run an action
that requires authentication
on good.com.
So without XSRF protection,
the user--if the user is still
logged in to good.com,
that action will be run.
And the reason why
is because
when the browser navigates
to a URL,
it automatically is going
to send all of its cookies
and the HTTP headers
to the server.
That means if you're still
logged in to a site,
and you go to that URL,
it's automatically
going to send
your login cookies
to that site.
So if evil.com's
linking you there,
and it's, you know,
posting some form to that site,
and you're still logged in,
sure enough, your cookies
are going to get sent
and that site's going
to allow you to run that action.
So an example in the Playground
would be the save action.
If evil.com were
to link to "Save Code"
in the Playground,
and you the user
were still logged in
and clicked this link,
it would allow evil.com
to save code
into the Playground for you.
So why is this bad?
It's bad for obvious reasons.
It allows evil.com to access
and modify private data
on authenticated sites.
So one way to fix this
is to only let known domains
access and modify
sensitive data.
The way that you do this is
by creating a unique token
that the server and client
are going to share,
and that's how the server
is going to validate
that we're coming
from the correct origin.
Let's take a look
at this diagram I created.
In the Playground,
when a user clicks "login"
it's going to send the login
request to the server.
The server is then going
to create a unique token.
This unique token is
then sent back to the client.
The client immediately
stores it in cookies,
and whenever
they try and perform
an authenticated
action again,
they're going
to grab those cookies,
they're going to take
that unique token,
and they're going to put it
in POST form
to be sent off.
The reason
why this is important--
the whole cookies part,
grabbing it and putting it
in a POST form--
is because in JavaScript
you can only grab cookies
for the domain that you're on.
So if I'm on
code.google.com,
I'm the only person
that can run JavaScript
to access those cookies.
Evil.com can't
access those cookies.
So if evil--
if I require on the server
that you send
in the POST form
a unique token,
evil.com
can't do that token
because they can't
grab those cookies
from code.google.com.
Yes, the cookies will be sent
in the HTTP headers,
but we're
specifically looking
in the CGI args
to make sure
that this unique token's
being sent.
So in that manner,
you can verify
that on the server
that the request is coming
from the origin that you want.
So for authenticated actions
we only want to let it come from
domains that we're aware of.
All right, on to
front-end web performance.
So performance
is really important.
And Google's done
a lot of studies
that show that when you increase
the performance of your site
you receive more traffic.
And I got some of these numbers
from Steve Souders down here.
I don't know if you guys
were able to attend his session.
I think it was yesterday.
It was very good.
But thanks for
the numbers, Steve.
So if you increase your site
by 500 milliseconds--
well, at Google
we did a test
where if we
increased the load time
of Google
by 500 milliseconds,
then it would decrease
the traffic by 20%.
So that's definitely
significant.
And right now, back-end
servers are really fast.
So the amount of time
that it takes
for you to request
an HTML page from a server
and actually get it back--
I mean, it's really fast.
There's--you can
optimize it and--
but you're only going
to be optimizing milliseconds.
If you really want to optimize
the user experience
and make it so that
a person's seeing a web page
as fast as they can,
then you want
to focus on the front end.
So I should also mention
that, you know,
all the stuff I've learned
I've learned from Steve.
So you guys should definitely
go check out his blog
'cause he's got a lot
of really good resources.
So optimizing the Playground
was a really fun thing for me
because I got a lot
of gain out of it
with fairly little work.
It only took me
maybe a day or two
to do a bunch of these things.
And I went from a 400k app
down to a 90k app.
And the page now loads
with a primed cache
in just under 2 seconds.
So there are several things
that I did.
These are just really
simple, easy ways
that you can
increase performance,
and that's gzipping responses,
minifying JavaScript,
using correct
script tag placement,
optimal cache headers
and minimizing images.
So I'm going
to go through these,
explain a little bit about them,
and show some demos.
Gzipping is
the biggest space saver.
Everyone should definitely
be doing gzip,
because you can get
70% space savings,
and it usually is only
one or two lines of config
on your server.
Gzipping--everyone knows
about zipping a file.
Gzipping's just the same.
You compress it on the server.
When someone requests
a resource,
and then on the client,
they're going to get
this zipped response.
They're going to unzip it
and then evaluate it.
One interesting thing
to note
is that I was using AppEngine
so I didn't have
to worry about this at all.
AppEngine has it
on by default.
But for things like Apache,
it's really easy to Google
how to do this.
So let's take a look
at the space savings I got.
Going to go into Why Slow...
and take a look
at the components.
So here you can see
a couple of the JavaScript files
that I have.
And I went from
an original 55K file
and now it's about 18K.
And then a 35K file
down to a 10K file.
So for adding, you know,
one line to your config
it's pretty much the easiest
thing you can do
to increase the performance
of your website.
Minifying JavaScript--
what that is is--
well, minifying JavaScript
as well as CSS.
What that is is just taking out
unnecessary characters--
newlines, comments,
tabs, spaces.
There's a bunch of tools
for doing it.
There's also tools
for doing JavaScript compiling,
where you actually use,
like, Rhino or something
to evaluate the JavaScript
and change some of the logic.
But these
are just minifiers.
I use YUI Compressor.
It's good because, you know,
I can use it
in my open source project.
It's stable and it's fast
and does a good job for me.
Minifying JavaScript
is bad for production,
or, excuse me,
good for production
but bad for development.
And the reason why
is because
it takes out all
the unnecessary characters.
So if you're developing,
you want to be able to easily
read and edit your code
and you also want to be able
to find errors.
So if you use
minified JavaScript
while you're developing
and you have an error,
then the error's pretty much
always going to be on line 1.
[audience quietly chuckles]
You can save 20% or 30%
of the size.
So I'm just going to show
you guys really quick
what it was like for me.
Grab this script here.
Just want to show you guys
one line of it.
This is
the only important line.
This is the line
that does the magic.
It compresses
my interactive logic script.
Just go ahead
and run that script.
So here is my ugly
minified JavaScript.
So you can tell why you wouldn't
want to develop with this
because it's
very hard to read.
But it's perfect
for production
because it's optimized.
Down here are the sizes.
So before
I ran minify on it,
it was about 40K.
And then down here
after I minified it
it was 22K.
So in this case,
I got a 50% savings.
But that's not
the actual case,
because after I gzip
these two files
I only get about
a 30% savings.
Script tag placement--
this definitely
can make or break
your web application.
You have to be very wary
of where you're putting
the script tags on the page.
If you put lots
of script tags on your page,
it's definitely going
to slow it down.
And if you put script tags
in the head element,
that's bad, because as
the browser is going down
and parsing things
on the HTML page,
it's going to get
to these scripts
and it's going to start
downloading and executing
the scripts.
But that's not important
to the user.
The user doesn't care.
The user wants to see
the layout of your page
when they
first go to it.
They're not going to be able
to use any function
on your page
in the first 100 milliseconds
that it's loaded.
So you don't need to have
the function there for them.
Instead it's more important
that a user sees everything
immediately.
And so by putting
script tags in the head,
you're basically
slowing down the browser
from rendering
what it, you know,
the--the layout.
So what you do want to do
is put script tags
at the bottom of the body.
You want to dynamically
append script tags as well.
That's--that's even better.
But you can only do that
if the scripts
don't rely on each other.
So I'm going to show
some timelines.
I like to use
Safari's editor--
or, excuse me,
network timeline.
Let's open up
all three of these.
So I'm just printing out
the code to the page
so you guys
can see it.
So this is the bad way.
This is how you
don't want to do it.
This is adding
five JavaScripts in
to the head element.
It's bad because
there's a lot of them.
It's better to just have
one JavaScript
than it is to have five.
And it's bad because
it's in the head element
and it doesn't allow
the rest of the page
to render first.
You'll see over here,
by doing it this way,
you've got
this stair step effect.
So one JavaScript
downloads and executes,
then the next,
then the next--
so bad behavior.
Better behavior would be
to just have one single script
and have it
at the bottom of the body.
So taking a look at this...
gives you pretty much
what you would expect.
Just one JavaScript loading.
It's definitely faster.
And here is how you would
dynamically append the scripts.
Remember:
you only do this
if the scripts don't
depend on each other.
So up here I've got
my nice little function,
dynamicallyAppendScript.
Just going to create
a new script element,
assign its source,
give it a type,
and append it.
Down here I am going to take
my five JavaScripts
and I'm going to load them.
And you'll notice
that the benefit of this
is that when you
dynamically append them,
all of the JavaScript
will download in parallel.
So the browser
can start downloading
all five of these JavaScripts,
and then it'll execute them
as soon as they download.
So that would be bad
if the JavaScript
has to execute
in a certain order.
But otherwise,
it's certainly better
than putting a bunch of script
tags at the top of your page.
Cache headers--
so I'm sure you guys
are familiar
with setting cache headers.
Basically just
what you want to do
is set the Expires header
far in the future.
What we do
is we set our headers
for about a year
in advance.
And we just use
different names for our files.
So we version
our resources
with an md5sum.
So if, you know,
JavaScript version 1.JS,
set it for a year
in advance,
and so that takes advantage
of the cache.
If we never change
the version of our JavaScript
for a full year,
then everyone out there
has got it cached for a year.
Otherwise, you know,
if 15 days later
we decide we need
to release a new version,
then we'll release
JavaScript 2.JS.
And since it's a new name,
it won't be associated
with the cache
of the other version,
so we've got
the best of both worlds.
We can release new versions
as fast as we want,
but if we don't release
a new version
then it's going to be
cached for a long time.
So if you want to see
what other servers--
or, excuse me,
other companies are doing
with cache editors,
you can use any
of these tools below
to inspect the requests that
are happening in your browser.
And you can
actually inspect
their cache editors.
And setting cache editor
is pretty easy--
again, you just do it
on the server in the config.
Oops. Didn't mean
to skip out of there.
Minimizing images--so images
take up a lot of space.
And there's two things
that you can do
to prevent this:
compressing images
and using image spriting.
Here are three images.
And I'm going to show you
how to compress them
and then how to sprite them.
So first I want to use
this cool tool
that--that the Yahoo guys
just bought.
It's called Smush.it.
Go ahead and click that,
and it's going to take
all of the images on my page
and it's going
to optimize them for the web.
So they're still
going to have, you know,
roughly the same quality.
You won't be able to tell
a difference in the quality
with your eye.
But it's going to make them
a lot smaller.
So this is kind of
the same thing
as if you go into Photoshop
and when you've got a picture
you click "export
for web optimization".
See, here I saved 12K,
which is actually
a significant amount.
Let's say that,
you know--
the Playground
is 10K right now.
So that would be saving 10%
on the website.
So when you have
a lot of images
and you optimize them,
you can actually save
a decent amount of bandwidth.
Spriting images--
so spriting images
is when you take
multiple images
and turn them
into one image,
and then the way that you
address each different image
is with CSS rules.
So here are three images.
Here is what those
three images would look like
as one image.
You can tell that I'm just
accessing sprite.png here.
And the way
that I created this
is with this nice tool
that I found online.
It's called Sprite Gen.,
and it's very simple to use.
You just zip up
all of your images.
So I've got an archive
of all my images.
There are some options
that you set,
and then you click
"Create Sprite"
and it's going to give me
my image right here.
I can download it.
And I can also grab
the CSS rules.
So these are the rules
for displaying
each separate image.
And so why would you
want to use image spreading?
The reason why is because
if you've got 50 images
on your page,
then the browser's going to have
to do 50 separate requests
for those images.
It's much better
for the browser
to just do one request
for the image
for all your stuff.
And actually,
if you look through
a lot of different properties
that Google owns--
and I'm sure
other major properties
or other major companies
like Yahoo--
you'll be able to find
their sprites very easily.
Like, there's--
there's giant sprites
for YouTube, for instance,
and you'll find,
like, one image
that has all the icons
that you'll recognize
that are used
all across YouTube.
Great, so I covered
a couple of different topics.
Maybe I bored some of you
with too much code or whatever,
but if you guys
have any questions
please feel free
to come up to the mics,
and thank you for coming.
[applause]
woman: That was
a very interesting talk.
I have a question, though.
Regarding your breakpoints,
the place where you had written
the code for the breakpoints,
and you said it's--the user's
code is actually running
on a different domain.
Lisbakken:
Yeah.
woman: In an iFrame.
Lisbakken: Yeah.
woman: So if you could go
to that slide, please.
So how is the user's code
kind of getting embedded
in your [indistinct] spot,
when it's actually
in an iFrame.
Lisbakken:
Okay, so...so you're asking
how did I get the code
and put it in the...
or are you asking me
how does it get to the iFrame?
woman: Yeah--
what I'm asking is
because this code, the var
"A" equals text and alert
is actually a part
of the iFrame code.
So how would it
actually get--
how would you execute it
at that point
after your breakpoint
is done?
Lisbakken: Yeah,
so the answer is you can't.
The way that it happens
is that right here
when I'm typing code,
when I type,
you know, "alert"--
woman: Mm-hmm.
Lisbakken: And I put
a breakpoint in right here,
as soon as I go
to debug this code
and click "Run"
what's going to happen
is in my Playground code
I'm going to have
this block of text,
I'm going to parse
this whole block of text,
and I'm going to add in
my breakpoint code.
And then after I parse in
that code that I
just showed you before,
then I send it
to the other server,
and then it sends me back
the unique URL
and then I create
an iFrame to it.
So you can't do it
on the fly.
woman: Okay.
Lisbakken: 'Cause--yeah.
Lisbakken: Does that make sense?
woman: Yeah. And I have
another question for you.
So the place where you
dynamically appended
the scripts--
Lisbakken: Yeah.
woman: Is that going to be
five separate requests
or is it going to be
one single request?
Lisbakken: It's going to be
five separate.
woman: Okay. Thanks.
Lisbakken: Yep.
man: So on your "add properties
to an object" slide...
Lisbakken: On which slide?
man: Yeah, if you could just
jump back to that sl--
oh, yeah, sorry,
the co--
Lisbakken:
This one right here?
man: No, actually
the code, sorry.
In the Playground.
Lisbakken: One of
the JavaScript ones?
man: Yeah.
Lisbakken: Object Literals?
man: No, add properties
to an object...
Lisbakken: Oh. Yeah.
man: The second one.
Right. The a.function3
equals function, right?
This code, you state,
is the function.
But what happens
if the function's called
within an on--
an onclick or something?
Because at that point the scope
is the event, right?
Lisbakken:
It's the event handler.
So...well, actually, no.
It'll refer to the DOM element.
So if you referred to this
on an onclick,
then you would get
the element of whatever...
man: Right, so--
so then--
what, I mean,
what are you doing--
what do you do
in that case?
Lisbakken: What do you mean,
what do you do with it?
Oh, what do you do
in that case?
man: Yeah, because
the property's...
property1 and property2
are not going to be accessible
at that point in time, so how
do you scope this function
such that
I can still call this
as part of--
in response to a click
or some other function?
I mean, I want that--
I want still to be able to get
to property1 and property2.
Lisbakken:
Oh, okay. So...
someone said it down here.
Was it you, Jeremy?
Yeah, so that was one of the
other examples that I showed--
that was
in closure for events.
So because in this event
when I have
an onclick handler--
this is going to be
referring to button.
man: Right.
Lisbakken: Right?
And so, you know, I don't--
I don't want that.
Instead,
what I wanted
was I wanted
this variable "I"
to be passed in.
And so what I had done
is I'd used closure
to basically snapshot "I"
and get it
into this outer function
so that the inner function
could then call it.
[indistinct chatter]
The--the--so the way
that closure works
is that an inner function
can access the context
of the outer function.
man: That--
I know that part.
But I'm just saying that--
I'm asking you
how would you
rewrite that function
so that you do still have
the scope of "A"
in the context
of the fact
that it's being called
within an event?
Lisbakken: What you can do
is, like,
you can actually say
like var self is equal to this,
and then I could pass
self in.
And then up here
I'd have self
and then I could call
self.--
oh, I forgot--
property1.
Does that make sense?
man: Sure.
Lisbakken: You could
essentially grab
the--the--
this keyword
in whatever you are.
So in the last sample, if--
Let's see, where was it?
man: Yeah, essentially
creating a closure
where you're going to keep...
Lisbakken: So in here
if I were to create, like,
var button is equal to,
you know,
document.createElement
"A", a new anchor,
and say button.onclick
is equal to a new function.
If I wanted to pass in...
if I wanted the inner function
to be able to have access
to this.property1,
then what I would do
is I would go like this.
man: Just total property
which is...
Lisbakken: I would say
self is equal to this,
so now I've got access to it.
And call buttonClick.
And then pass in self.
And up here
I'd create my closure.
Click...
So I just did that
on the fly.
Let's see if it works.
Oh, wait, I didn't--
I didn't
put the button anywhere.
[all chuckle]
Let's see...
Get--what am I looking for?
Why am I blanking right now?
Get...
man: You could just
write down a function
which does the self.--
Lisbakken:
getElementsByTagName
body.appendChildButton.
[indistinct chatter]
Oh. Thanks, guys.
[chuckles]
This is not going to work
because this is
at the top of the document.
Hold on a sec, let me--
[all laugh]
The body won't be
defined at that point.
So let's go ahead
and edit the HTML.
Oh, okay. Looks like
the JavaScript is in the body.
Okay.
Please work.
man: [chuckles]
Lisbakken:
[groans] Oh.
The--the button
has no inner HTML.
Come on, guys.
[all laugh]
There we go.
There's my button.
There we go--
that's property1.
[applause]
man: Awesome.
You did write...
Lisbakken:
So I could export this
and go ahead
and send it to you.
[all laugh]
man: Thanks.
man: I was just
going to ask when you--
before when you overrided
the string.concat...
Lisbakken: Yeah.
man: I was curious
as to whether or not
it would override the plus
operator between strings,
and then also,
if it doesn't,
how would you--
how could you--
can you, sorry...
Lisbakken:
Override the plus operator?
man: Override the plus operator,
like, in C++?
Lisbakken:
I don't think that's possible.
Maybe someone else knows?
man: You cannot.
Lisbakken: I don't think so.
Yeah, you cannot.
man: So--but so
by overriding concat,
string plus string would
still just concatenate?
Lisbakken: 'Cause--yeah,
you can only do it
with, like, with types.
So it's an operator.
man: Okay.
Lisbakken: Yep.
man: Thanks.
man: Totally
unrelated question--
I'm having a problem trying
to control the context
of document.write.
I've got an issue where
I'm dropping something
and I--I wish
I could move that.
And let's say, you know,
let's say I have an add code
and it's--
when I get it back,
it's using
document.write.
Have you had any--or heard
of any experiments
where you can control that?
Lisbakken: Generally, you
shouldn't use document.write.
man: Yeah, I know, but
it's a third party, you know.
Lisbakken: Oh, so you have
to use document.write?
man: They are using
document.write in their code
and we're just making
reference to the script.
Lisbakken: Um...
it sounds like
I'd have to see the code.
So maybe
we can talk right after.
man: All right.
Lisbakken: Would that be okay?
man: Yeah.
man: Hi. You had that trick
of sending your code to a server
which then basically
sent it back to you
with a unique URL
to stick in the iFrame.
What would happen if you
pointed the iFrame
at, like, a data URL?
Lisbakken: At what?
man: A data URL.
Lisbakken:
A data URL?
man: I think
that's what it's called.
It's like a URL where
you can hard-code some data
and...is that
what it's called?
Do people know
what I'm talking about?
Lisbakken: I mean,
it's just going to--
it's going to try
and render the iFrame,
and since it's going to be
data and not HTML
it's just going to fail.
man: Okay.
Lisbakken: I mean...
man: I'll have to try it.
Thanks.
woman: Can you actually
change the prototype property
for the function object
itself?
And have you done
anything interesting
and needed to do that ever?
Lisbakken:
I believe you can.
But it's a bad idea
because everyone
uses functions, so...
[all chuckle]
woman: All right. Thanks.
man: Hi.
Is it not possible to load
JavaScript files dynamically
as the document
is being loaded?
Remember how you added
the five files at the end,
and they were
running in parallel?
Well, why not call--
as the document is loaded,
have, like, points,
which execute
dynamic loading?
So you don't manually
code it in
but the server
executes JavaScript code.
So it renders
on the client side,
JavaScript code for--
dynamically loading
different JavaScript files,
so that as
the document loads,
on parallel the JavaScript files
will also load.
Lisbakken:
So actually...
my example
does actually do that.
And let me show you
why really quick.
So what happens is
my dynamicallyAppend--
these happen
in the head element.
And so what I'm doing
for each dynamicAppend
is I'm appending it
to the head.
So the browser right now
is parsing and executing
all this code.
Meanwhile imagine, right after
this script tag,
I'm now adding all these
new script tags after it.
So as soon as it's done
with this block of code,
it's going to start
executing or downloading
those scripts
that I've told it to do.
But because they're
dynamically appended,
it frees up
the browser thread.
So the browser thread
sees it, and it goes,
"Oh, here's the script tag
that I need to do."
It starts downloading it,
but then it moves past
and keeps going.
So that's why
in the timeline
you saw that--
well, this isn't in Safari.
But in the timeline
that's why you saw
they all started
at the same time.
The reason why is because
browser thread came down,
"Okay, I need to start
downloading this.
Okay, I'm done.
I'll wait till it comes back."
Executes, or comes--
finishes downloading
before I
start executing it.
man: I was thinking--
you're already doing it.
I was thinking of
more of the line--same lines
but you just
have a script tag without--
type script,
dynamicLoad, endScript
somewhere along the body.
Not--not at the beginning
but you essentially
break the body
into different portions.
Lisbakken: Yeah.
man: And then you
just load it
at different parts
of the body.
Lisbakken: Yeah.
man: But--yeah.
That's cool.
Okay. Thanks.
Lisbakken:
Anything else?
man: Hi. Is it possible
to extend a namespace
like you created with
the anonymous function
across multiple
JavaScript files?
Lisbakken: Yes.
man: Yes?
Would you just make
a non-anonymous function and...
Lisbakken:
You're just saying, like,
use basically the same variables
across functions,
but each file is gonna have
its own anonymous function.
Is that what you're saying?
man: Well, I saw that you
used the global namespace
to--to pass those variables,
but I was wondering if you could
keep it in the same namespace
and not use
the global namespace.
Lisbakken: I think I know
what you're talking about.
Let me actually go
to the code that I wrote
for the Playground and...
see if--see, where is it--
anonymous functions?
I had a link in here for...
So what I'm doing here
is right at the start
of all my code
I'm declaring
anonymous function.
And then all through here,
all this stuff
is just local
to this function.
It's never going to touch
the global namespace at all.
Then at the very end,
I go through
and I create this variable,
"IS", on the global namespace.
And it's going to be equal
to a new instance
of all of my code.
As so basically
I've created one pointer
on the global object
that is now going to have--
this one variable
is now going to have
access to everything
that I've created inside.
So I've been,
you know,
I've kept my code very green.
man: Yeah, yeah.
Lisbakken: No...
minimal pollution.
man: Nice, okay.
Lisbakken: Is it--
does that answer your question?
man: It does. Yeah.
Lisbakken: Okay.
Great.
So for those of you out there
that are JavaScript experts,
please, you know,
check out the project,
fix my code for me,
and--
[chuckles]
create your own samples
with the framework,
because
it's pretty easy to do.
Yeah?
man:
So my question is...
I've heard the argument
against gzipping as well.
And I'm just wondering...
like, I like the idea--
I've always liked the idea
of minimizing
my JavaScript files.
But, like, for instance,
one of the reasons
jQuery doesn't gzip
their files anymore--
they only minify them--
is because they found that
the potential overhead
from gzipping them--
from having to unzip them
on the client side
tended to be less effective
than just
not zipping them at all.
And I'm wondering when,
I guess, as a developer,
you should consider
zipping your files
as opposed
to just minifying them
and throwing them
on the server?
Lisbakken:
I have never heard that--
that argument--
that the processing overhead
is--takes more time.
Because I'd imagine if someone
has a really slow connection
and a slow computer--
let's say
an 800 megahertz computer
and a 56K modem--
it's gonna
take a lot more time
to download that extra 50K
versus unzip it.
But Steve Souders
would definitely be
the better person to ask,
'cause this is what he
studies at Google every day.
So...
man: Pay him a visit.
Lisbakken: Yep.
man: Thank you.
Lisbakken: Uh-oh.
I know this guy.
man: This is just
an easy question.
Do you have office hours
today, man?
Lisbakken:
I do have office hours today.
[audience chuckles]
man: When are they?
Lisbakken: I think they're
right after this session.
man: Do you want everyone
here to come see you?
Lisbakken:
No. I'm just kidding, yeah.
If you guys have
any extra questions,
please, it's just over
on the other side.
You'll see all the booths
with windows on them
and that's where all
the Googlers will hang out
to answer questions.
So I'll be over there
at the AJAX API booth.
So...
please come see me.
[chuckles]
Thanks, Dwight.
[applause]